just be nice to people you know I'm
working on it you know always trying to
get better
good dance
it's all jokes
your fears
your fears
video games cause violence come on video
games don't cause violence bam video
games cause carpal tunnel and vaginal
dryness
every now and then we should all go to a
completely incorrect speakeasy
so we're gonna all go to say horrible
stuff but nobody cares you got no Hate
in Your Heart you don't want to hurt
anybody but if you can't say it there
give us a place yeah right you go down
some creaky stairs you bang on a big
steel door the guy's like what's the
password [ __ ]
[Music]
I'll be watching two seconds of gay porn
she flipped out
she was like what the hell is going on
here I was like well
you watch murder
isn't that way weirder she was like oh
shut up I'm just watching my show so I
know what to do if I ever get in that
situation I'm like maybe that's why I'm
watching gay porn
[Music]
video games cause violence come on video
games don't cause violence damn video
games cause carpal tunnel and vaginal
dryness
[Music]
I'll be hanging out with a friend he's
like all right man take it easy I'm
gonna go work on arms and back I'm like
cool I'm gonna go work on letting go of
the past and accepting love
everybody loves the gym oh the gym makes
me feel sexy well you know what else is
sexy not being a walking red flag
nobody cares about your abs if you're
the guy having a meltdown at Chili's
and look you know if you get upset or
offended that's cool I'm not one of
those guys you're allowed to be offended
that's totally cool but if you are just
shut up
you're not a hero you're just running a
show just be offended just let it flow
through you just feel it right
I don't share we don't care just feel
yeah we all have thoughts I might want
to sleep with your girlfriend I just
hold it in I don't say yeah
I don't need any of this stuff I'm just
saying words in a certain order to
elicit laughter we're like trying to
figure me out do my ACT it's all jokes I
told an abortion joke recently and a
woman approached me she was like hey
that's very insensitive I've had an
abortion you shouldn't tell jokes like
that I was like whoa hey sorry I just
told a joke I think what you did was
much worse
[Music]
You Can Dance
your feared and face your fears
video games cause violence come on video
games don't cause violence
cause carpal tunnel and vaginal dryness